over the weekend bitcoin crashed
aggressively there's a lot of people
wondering what was going on in order to
better understand what happened you need
to understand the structural differences
between the new market and the old
legacy financial market the new market
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies it trades
24 7 365. it's always on but the legacy
financial system has hours of operations
it's not open over the weekend and of
course on a weekend like this it's a
three-day weekend because monday serves
as a bank holiday and so going into the
weekend everyone knew that for three
days you would not be able to move fiat
currencies from your bank into a crypto
exchange to be able to buy any more
bitcoin or cryptocurrencies this means
that there is no buyer of last resort it
means that that persistent bid that
inflow of new capital as prices drop
wasn't going to be there and so
naturally as the bitcoin price started
to fall and there were no new buyers
that meant that the price was only going
to continue in free fall and so as
bitcoin went down and down and down it
started to trigger liquidations and
that's where we saw a cascading effect
liquidation after liquidation after
liquidation that led to not only for
sellers but also panic and fear in the
market
now that we're on the other side of the
weekend we see that over seven billion
dollars of losses were captured over the
last three days if we go ahead and we
take a look here this coindesk article
looked at the glass node data and it
shows that approximately 555 000 bitcoin
changed hands between eighteen thousand
and twenty three thousand dollar price
of bitcoin which served both as a strong
support and a resistance but the losses
are ranging between one point five
billion and two billion dollars every
single day and if you look at the
historical comparison on the chart you
can see a massive spike in all of the
losses that investors were taking
all the way here on the far right you
can see that it was the highest number
of realized loss ever in history and so
of course yes plenty of investors were
simply selling because they wanted to
they were fearful of what could happen
but many of them actually were for
sellers they were being liquidated
because they had too much leverage in
the system
so naturally as you begin to look at
this past weekend and you realize there
was seven billion dollars of losses
understand that a lot of it had to do
with the market structure difference
between the new world and the old world
if more people weren't able to take fiat
currencies and get it into the crypto
systems get it onto those exchanges and
be able to buy these lower prices it
meant that bitcoin was going to continue
to fall until eventually either all the
liquidations had already happened or
there was an exhaustion of the sellers
we saw bitcoin trade all the way down in
the 17 000s we're back up above 20 000
now no one has a crystal ball no one
knows what the future holds but what we
do know is that whenever you see a long
weekend like what's coming up in july
4th you've got to understand that there
are no new funds to flow into the crypto
system and it's likely to have
significant volatility during those
times this was a three-day weekend over
july 4th as somebody like arthur hayes
recently pointed out it's a five-day
break
so of course you should understand the
difference in market structure and you
should be prepared for these moments
everyone needs to understand that when
no new funds can flow from the old
system into the new system that
volatility almost always happens hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time